preparándose para un viaje muy largo
muchos se despertaron temprano algunos
se llevaron una grata sorpresa dijeron
que solo uno de cada diez trenes pero en
realidad todos los trenes estaban en
Operación Así que tengo tiempo para un
café y llegaré al trabajo súper temprano
otros no tuvieron tanta suerte es un
auténtico desastre no tengo trenes para
ir tengo que un tren de aquí y
luego tengo que encontrar un autobús
para ir más lejos no sé cuánto tardaré
excepto en las horas pico los servicios
de tren y metro se mantienen al mínimo
de operación mucha gente prefirió
trabajar desde casa teniendo que
ocuparse de sus hijos los sindicatos
afirman que el 50% de los profesores de
primaria están en huelga la primera
ministra ha descartado dar marcha atrás
en el núcleo de la Reforma de las
pensiones retrasar la edad de jubilación
de los 62 a los 64 años pero el gobierno
se enfrenta a una ardua batalla con
legisladores no solo de la oposición
sino también del partido gobernante que
expresan su preocupación
al empezar a estudiar el texto muchos
esperan que el gobierno haga algunas
concesiones en ámbitos como el de las
mujeres los trabajadores en condiciones
difíciles y la contratación de personas
mayores
podemos percibir cierto nerviosismo por
parte de la mayoría al empezar nuestro
trabajo cuando vemos crecer esta
oposición entiendo porque vacilan les
escucharemos responderemos cada grupo ha
presentado una serie de enmiendas solo
la alianza de izquierda ha presentado
miles y miles de enmiendas
es un abuso de la comisión y en cierto
modo vergonzoso
el debate en la asamblea nacional
continuará hasta el 17 de febrero antes
de que el texto pase al senado